สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไร
คะวันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 16
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ 2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันศุกร์วันที่
เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 17
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
:00 นค่ะ
ค่ะ 3 ทุ่ม 33 นาทีเป็นเวลากลางคืน
ใช่เป็นเวลากลางคืนนะคะดึกแล้ว
อะไรนะ
ดึกแล้ว
3 ทุ่มสำหรับครูฟ้าดึกเหรอคะเพราะว่าถ้า
สำหรับครูหญิงเนี่ย 3 ทุ่มดึกแล้วแต่ครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยปกติครูฟ้านอนตอนตี 2 ครูฟ้านอน
เนี่ย 3 ทุ่มไม่ดึกนะถ้าดึกสำหรับครูฟ้า
อาจจะเป็นเที่ยงคืน
ตอนนี้ 3 ทุ่มดึกแล้วหรอคะ
ก็ไม่ดึกหรอกค่ะ
อ้าว 21:00 นเนี่ยนะคะเป็นเวลากินข้าวของ
คุณฟ้าค่ะ
ปกติ 3 ทุ่มเนี่ยไม่ดึกสำหรับครูฟ้าค่ะ
ครูฟ้า
แต่ถ้าครูหญิงเนี่ยดึกแล้ว 3 ทุ่มครึ่ง
แล้วครูหญิงจะนอนแล้วดึกแล้วพี่ฟ้าเนี่ย
กินข้าวอยู่นะคะ
[เพลง]
คือช่วงนี้เนี่ยก็กำลัง
ใช้ชีวิตนะคะในตอน 3 ทุ่ม
ถ้าเป็นเด็กใช่ไหมคะอายุ
32 ยังเด็กอยู่อีกหรอต้องนอนแล้ว 0 ขวบ
ไปเลยแล้วกันนะคะเนี่ยเด็กๆเนี่ย 3 ทุ่ม
เนี่ยถ้ายังไม่นอน
พ่อแม่ไม่โอเคนะดึกแล้ว
ยังกินข้าวอยู่เลยนะคะนักเรียนแล้วก็
กินข้าวแล้วก็เล่นกับแมว
ได้ค่ะ
นี่คือแมวฟ้านะคะ
แก้มแมว
จมูกแมวนะคะปากแมวมันยิ้มใส่เรา
หนวดแมวมี 3 เส้นนะคะ
ตาของแมวทำไมตามาที่หลังสุดแมวหลับตาเหรอ
คะครูฟ้าอ๋อมีลูกตาด้วย
หน้าตา
ครูฟ้าเป็นเล่นกับแมวตอนประมาณ
3 ทุ่มครึ่งเหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะ
แมวครูฟ้าเองเพราะว่าที่บ้านครูฟ้ามีแมว
เวลากินลูกเสร็จตอน 21:00 นนะคะแมว
ค่ะเดินไปเล่นกับแมว
เดินมาเล่นกับแมวนะคะ
แมวครูฟ้าเนี่ยน่ารักค่ะ
ทุกคนบอกว่าแมวตัวเองน่ารักใช่ไหมคะนัก
เรียน
มีแมวผู้หญิงก็บอกว่าอุ๊ยแมวครูหญิงน่า
รักนักเรียนมีแมวนักเรียนก็บอกว่าแมวนัก
เรียนน่ารักค่ะแมวของเราเนี่ยเราก็รู้สึก
น่ารักแล้วทำไมอ่ะครูฟ้าวันนี้ครูฟ้าจะมา
เล่าเกี่ยวกับเรื่องของแมวครูฟ้าเหรอคะ
ผู้หญิงเก่งมากค่ะไม่ได้เล่าเรื่องเกี่ยว
กับแมวกูฟ้านะคะแต่ครูฟ้ามีนิทานมาเล่า
ให้ฟัง
นิทานเนี่ยชื่อว่า
แมวครูฟ้า
นิทานไม่มีคำว่าแมวค่ะ
ลูกกระพรวน
อะไรคือลูกตำรวจครูฟ้าใส่ลูกกับพรวนไว้
ที่คอให้แมวทำไมอ่ะ
เขาเรียกว่า
เวลาแมวภูฟ้าเดินไปไหนครูฟ้าจะได้ยินมัน
จะดัง
ใช่ครับเป็นลูกกับพรวนนะ
ใช่นิทานเรื่องนี้ชื่อว่า
ลูกกระพรวน
กับอะไร
หนู
ไม่รู้ได้ยังไง
อย่างนี้ก็ใช่หรอ
ใช่
แต่ถ้าใส่ให้แมวถ้าใส่ให้แมว
มันจะแบบ
ประมาณนี้ไหมลูกก็พรวนของแมวนะคะ
นิทานของครูฟ้าก็คือลูกกับพรวนกับหนูแล้ว
เรื่องมันเป็นยังไงคะ
ครูฟ้าพูดภาษาไทยฟังเข้าใจ 50% ครูฟ้าพูด
ภาษาอังกฤษฟังเข้าใจ 5% อ้าว
กาลครั้งหนึ่งนานมาแล้ว
มีอะไรคะครูฟ้า
ก็มีบ้านอยู่ 1 หลังนะคะก็วาดบ้าน
มาหาครูฟ้า
หลังคาบ้านเนี่ย
มันจะแหลมอะไรขนาดนั้น
มีบ้านอยู่ 1 หลัง
แล้วยังไงอ่ะ
คือในบ้านนี้นะคะ
ก็มีหนู
มีหนูกี่ตัวคะไหนบ้านหลังนี้เนี่ย
อู้หูมากกว่ามากกว่า 1 ตัวหรอ
ใช่ค่ะมีหนูมากกว่า 1 ตัวนะคะเขาเรียกว่า
อยู่กันเป็นครอบครัวหนูอ่ะ
มีแม่มีลูกมีปู่มีย่ามีตามียาไหมมีลุงมี
ป้ามีน้ำมีน้ำมีอานะคะซึ่ง
หนูเนี่ยอาจจะบวกไม่บวกคูณ
อาจจะมากกว่า 10 ตัว
ซึ่งนอกจากในบ้านนี้มีหนูแล้วนะคะในบ้าน
นี้ก็ยังมี
อะไรอีกคะแมว
ทำไมแมวตัวใหญ่มากเลยอ่ะใหญ่เท่าบ้านเลย
อ่ะ
เหมือนบ้านครูฟ้าเลยที่บ้านครูฟ้าก็มีแมว
อ๋อ
แมวอยู่
ในบ้าน
พี่แมวอะไรอีกคะทำไมตัวใหญ่เท่ากับบ้าน
เลย
แล้วที่บ้านหลังนี้เนี่ยมีหนูมากกว่า 10
ตัวแล้วมีแมวกี่ตัวคะ
มีแมว 1 ตัวค่ะ
เหลือแค่ 1 ตัวเองหรอ 1 ตัว
โอเคได้ค่ะแล้วเป็นยังไงต่อคะ
แมวเนี่ยก็ชอบจับหนูใช่ไหมคะเพราะว่านี่
This  Is  Tom  and  Jerry นะคะแต่
เจอร์รี่คงจะ
รีบมีหลายหลายตัวนะคะอ๋อใช่ค่ะเวลาแมวมัน
เห็นหนูเนี่ยมัน
จับหนูเอามากิน
ถูกต้องค่ะวันนึงเนี่ยหมูก็เลยต้องมา
คุยกัน Meeting กันนะคะ
มีหนูๆๆๆเนี่ยคุยอะไรกันนะคะ
หนูประเทศไทยนะคะนักเรียนมันร้องจี๊ดๆได้
ยินเสียงไหมซูมตัดหรือเปล่า
หนูเนี่ยนะคะก็มาคุยกัน
คุยกัน
[เพลง]
หนูทั้งหมดที่อยู่ในบ้านหลังนี้ใช่ไหมคะ
เพราะว่าแบบว่า
แมวมันจะจับเราทุกครั้งเลยอ่ะตัวนี้สบาย
จังเลยนะนอนแบบ
หนูก็คุยกันเรื่องอะไรอ่ะคะครูฟ้ามันต้อง
มาคุยกันว่าจะทำยังไงดีนะคะ
กับแมวที่ชอบจับหนู
จะสู้กับแมวยังไงหรอ
จะสู้กับแมวยังไงนะคะเพราะว่าถ้าเกิดหนู
โดนแมวจับทุกวันเนี่ยหนูก็ตายใช่ไหมต่าง
ตายตายตายตาย
ดูแล้ว
หนูก็เลยกันเพราะว่าหนูกลัวแมวไงใช่ไหม
ก็เลยต้องมา Meeting กันนะคะ How  to
Survive
หนูก็ต้องมาคุยคุยกันว่า
เราจะทำยังไงให้เราเนี่ยไม่ตายไม่โดนแมว
จับแล้วก็
กิน
ใช่ไหมถูกต้องค่ะหนูเนี่ยก็มาคุยกันแล้ว
ก็ลองให้ใครมีไอเดียดีๆก็พูดมาซิ
[เพลง]
กันนะคะไอเดีย
ทำยังไงดีนะทำไงดีนะพ่อหรือว่าเรา 10 ตัว
เนี่ยวิ่งไปกัดแมวดีไหมให้แมวตายอันนี้
ไอเดียหนูตัวที่ 1
มันจะโอเคเหรอ
หนูตัวที่ 2 บอกไม่ได้หรอกแมวตัวใหญ่เรา
สู้แมวไม่ได้
ตายหนูจะไม่ได้สู้แมวไม่ได้หนูตัวที่ 3
ก็บอกว่าทำแบบนี้ดีไหมเราเดินไปแล้วเราก็
ตบหัวแมวแล้วก็บอกว่าอย่ามายุ่งกับเรา
หมูตัวที่ 4 ก็ไม่ได้อันนี้แมวสูงเรา
เนี่ยเตี้ย
อันนี้หนูใช่ไหมหนู
หนูจะยื่นยังไงแล้วอันนี้แมว
หนูเนี่ยต้องกระโดดหรือเปล่าถึงจะตบหัว
แมวได้ไม่ได้ไม่ได้เราตบหัวแมวแมวก็จับ
แขนเราแล้วก็กินเรา
ไม่มีไอเดียดีๆเลยค่ะ
คุยกัน 1 ชั่วโมงเนี่ยก็ยังคิดไม่ได้เหรอ
คะว่าจะทำยังไง
จนกระทั่งมีหนูตัวหนึ่ง
เป็นที่
สีเขียว
เป็นหนูที่ฉลาดมากๆหรอ
หนูเด็กๆอาจจะหนูอายุสัก 18 อย่างนี้นะ
เหมือนขน
หนูตัวนี้เนี่ยก็บอกว่าเอาอย่างนี้สิเรา
มีไอเดีย
อุ๊ยมีไอเดียอะไรเหรอหนูสีเขียวดูสีเขียว
หนูน่ะบอกว่าเราก็ต้องหาลูกกระพรวน
อันนี้นะ
ใช่ค่ะ
ลูกกับผัวเนี่ย
หาลูกกระพรวนมาทำอะไร
หาลูกกระพรวนแล้วก็เอาไป
ห้อยคอแมว
ใช่ไหม
เอาไปห้อยคอแมวค่ะค่ะ
เพราะว่าลูกกระพรวนเนี่ยมันมีเสียง
จริงๆ
อ้า
[เพลง]
แมวใส่ลูกกระพรวน
แล้วแมวเดินไปเดินมาเดินไปทางขวาเดินไป
ทางซ้ายเราก็จะได้ยินเสียง
กรุ๊งกริ๊งอ๋อเราก็จะรู้ว่าตอนนี้แมวอยู่
ตรงไหนเราก็จะได้ไม่ไป
ในที่ที่แมวอยู่อ่ะหรอใช่ทำไมหนูสีเขียว
เนี่ยฉลาดมาก
แล้วจะเอาลูกกระพรวนไปผูกคอแมวยังไง
ใช่ค่ะนั่นคือพ้อย
หนูตัวที่หนูตัวที่ 800
มีหนู 10 ตัวค่ะ
หนูอีกตัวนึงอาจจะเป็นหนูตัวที่ 9 ก็ได้
หนูก็มีตัวที่ 1
อะไรนะคะ
[เพลง]
แล้วหนูอีกตัวนึงว่ายังไงครูฟ้าพูดมา
เดี๋ยวคุณหญิงวาดเอง
หนูอีกตัวนึงก็พูดเหมือนครูหญิงนั่นแหละ
ผู้หญิงว่า
อ้าว
มันเป็นไอเดียที่ดีนะ
แต่ใครจะเอาลูกกระพรวนไปผูกคอแมวล่ะ
เออหนูตัวที่เท่าไหร่จะทำ
หลังจากนั้นทุกคนก็เลยเงียบ
ไม่มีใครพูดว่ากลัวแมวมีคนก็กลัวแมวใช่
แล้ว
ก็เลย
จบ
แล้วเหลือแค่นี้นะ
คะนักเรียนคือหนูคิดได้แต่ไม่มีใครทำเอ้า
แล้วนิทานเรื่องนี้เนี่ยบอกอะไรเราอ่ะคะ
ครูฟ้านิทานเรื่องนี้ก็บอกว่าพูดง่ายทำ
ยาก
จริงๆแล้วหนูตัวสีเขียวเนี่ยก็อาจจะฉลาด
นะแต่หนูทุกตัวเนี่ยกลัวแมวใช่ไหมคะเรา
ฟังหนูตัวสีเขียวพูดแล้วคิดเก่งมากเลย
เก่งมากเลยเนาะพูดไงพูดแบบนี้นะเธอพวกเรา
นะต้องไปหาลูกกับพรวนแล้วก็เอาลูกกับพรวน
เนี่ย
เอาลูกกระพรวนมาที่คอของแมว
แล้วก็เอามาผูกที่คอของแมวเวลาแมวเดิน
เนี่ยเราจะได้ได้ยินไงล่ะว่าแมวอยู่ที่
ไหนทำไมหนูตัวอื่นๆเนี่ยคิดไม่ได้อ่าหนู
ตัวสีเขียวอาจจะบอกว่าโอ้เก่งมากหนูตัว
ที่ 1 ก็เลยถามแล้วใครจะเอาลูกกระพรวนไป
ผูกคอแมว
ไม่มีตัวก็
พูดอ่ะได้ใช่ไหมแต่ทำเนี่ยทำยาก
มันยากนะคะเออใช่ค่ะก็คือ
นิทาน
นักเรียนเราพูดง่ายๆคิดง่ายๆแต่พอจะทำ
มันไม่ง่ายใช่ไหม
คือเราเนี่ยคิดไว้แล้วนะว่าอ๋อเดี๋ยวเรา
จะทำแบบนี้ Step ที่ 1  Step ที่ 2  step
ที่ 3 แต่ละสเต็ปเนี่ยเราก็คิดเอาไว้แล้ว
ว่าเราจะทำยังไงครูหญิงก็อาจจะพูดบอกครู
ฟ้าใช่ไหมอาจจะบอกครูฟ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะ
ต้องทุกวันเนี่ยตื่นนอนมา 6 โมงเช้าแล้ว
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยก็มาวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งวิ่ง
วิ่งวิ่งวิ่งอาจจะไปวิ่งที่ฟิตเนสนะหรือ
ก็ไปวิ่งๆๆเนี่ย 1 ชั่วโมงเสร็จแล้วครู
ฟ้าก็ต้องกินแครอทครูฟ้าต้องกินผัก
ใช่ไหมครูฟ้าต้องกินผักครูฟ้าต้องกิน
ผลไม้
ทุกวันครูฟ้าห้ามกิน KFC นะครูฟ้าต้องทำ
แบบนี้เสร็จแล้วครูฟ้าก็ต้องนอนแต่
ชั่วโมงทุกวันทุกวัน
บอกครูฟ้าครูฟ้าถามแล้วครูหญิงทำได้ไหม
คุณนอน 8 ชั่วโมงงง
ผู้หญิงไม่ตื่นมาออกกำลังกายไม่กินผักไม่
กินผลไม้ใช่ไหมคุณหญิงเนี่ยพูดๆๆบอกให้
ครูฟ้าคำเนี่ยมันง่ายๆค่ะพูดอ่ะใครพูด
อะไรก็ได้ผู้หญิงก็ได้ว่าโอ้ครูหญิงเนี่ย
เป็นเพื่อนกับอีลอนมัสผู้หญิงพูดได้
ใครก็พูดได้
แต่จริงไหมไม่รู้ผู้หญิงก็พูดได้ผู้หญิง
เนี่ยขับเครื่องบิน
แอร์ฟอร์ซเนี่ยผู้หญิงทำได้แต่
ขับเครื่องบินจริงๆเนี่ย
โหไม่เข้าใจใช่ไหมคะ
เรื่องของวันนี้นะคะลูกกระพรวนกับหนูนะคะ
ก็จะสอนเราว่าบางอย่างเนาะพูดพูดได้ง่ายๆ
แต่ทำเนี่ยมันยากมันทำไม่ได้นะคะใช่ค่ะ
โอเคค่ะส่วนวิดีโอนี้ก็น่าจะแค่นี้นะคะ
เดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้าสวัสดี
ค่ะ